[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde la déconfiture du Maghreb
précisons que nous nous tiendrons à la
fraction territoriale la plus connue de
nous Français à savoir de trois pays
Algérie Maroc est Tunisie cet Afrique du
Nord jadis colonisée par la France nous
nous intéresserons pardon moins à
l'histoire coloniale de ces pays
diverses dans sa forme que diverssements
ressentis qu'au présent de ces trois
pays restaient proches de la France par
des populations mêlées des échanges
économiques et culturels des relations
politiques non dénuées de tension et une
commune appréhension sécuritaire
vis-à-vis du terrorisme au-delà de ce
voisinage nous chercherons à mettre
l'accent sur la situation économique et
politique de ce Maghreb arabe qu'il
maîtrise des difficultés économiques et
sociales qui se sont aggravés avec la
crise du covid de l'instabilité
politique suite à ce qu'on a appelé les
printemps arabes qui se sont traduits
par la contestation des jeunes
générations de la poussée islamiste
entraînant une régression de la
condition des femmes et d'autres
discriminations du terrorisme à la scène
d'Al-Qaïda et d'autres officines
djihadistes mais aussi des difficultés
de ces trois pays à coopérer entre eux
aucune intégration économique les
regroupant de leur rivalité régionale à
incarné le leadership auprès de
l'Afrique comme de l'Europe de leur
conflit territoriaux à propos du Sahara
Occidental bref de leur désunions et
même il faut bien le dire de la
déconfiture
socio-économique politique et
stratégique de cette région
nous allons chercher à comprendre ce
malaise arabe avec mes invités que je
vous présente Rachid temal vous êtes
sénateur PS c'est à dire Parti
socialiste du Val-d'Oise mais vous
présidez également le groupe d'amitié
France Algérie au Sénat Jean Dufourcq
vous êtes contre amiral et vous êtes
chercheur vous avez été rédacteur en
chef de la revue de défense nationale à
qui melkaroui vous êtes politologue et
aujourd'hui consultant et également
essayiste et Pierre Lelouch vous avez
été ministre député et vous êtes
consultant sur les relations
internationales
[Musique]
alors la question qui se pose c'est
qu'il y a eu ce qu'on a appelé le Irak
en Algérie en 2019
le premier printemps arabe s'est situé
en Tunisie en 2011 le Maroc a baptisé
avec le parti islamique pour former un
gouvernement
de toutes ces changements de toutes ces
révolutions selon le proverbe français
on pourrait dire tout change pour qu'à
la fin rien ne change quel est votre
avis rachitée mal c'est là vous parlez
de trois situations qu'on devrait
différences j'ai envie de dire que pour
la Tunisie ça a bien commencé mais ça
termine quasiment pire qu'avant j'ai
quand même l'évolution de du régime
actuel que ce soit sur les institutions
sur la pratique quand même assez
compliqué
sur l'Algérie il fait alors sur
l'Algérie c'est vrai qu'on a le
sentiment que tout est fait pour que on
vienne à la case départ
[Musique]
sur le Maroc il y a quand même une
capacité à se régénérer je trouve
démocratiquement qui est un peu plus
loin donc ces trois situations j'ai
envie de dire assez différentes mais qui
ont un point commun c'est la difficulté
à la fois des figées face à un pouvoir
qui quand même bloque les choses et on
voit bien que ces trois pays là ont un
peu je pense du mal à concevoir ce
qu'elle va tenir siècle et notamment
l'évolution de leur population comme ce
stage j'ai envie de dire libre donc mais
voilà il y a beaucoup de points communs
beaucoup de différence voilà ce que je
peux dire sur cette sur cette
comparaison j'ai envie de dire pierre
Lelouch qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
moi je pense que
vous avez raison de votre
question vous aviez raison puis ça
change plus c'est la même chose le
régime marocain c'est maintenu en
coptant dans un premier temps la
mouvance islamiste et puis la en quelque
sorte enzyme puisque ils sont plus au
gouvernement le roi est toujours là
solidement et le pays ma foi se
développe et se développe plutôt bien en
Afrique la situation en Algérie est
absolument inchangée c'est à dire que
les mêmes sont toujours au pouvoir
mélange de militaires et de d'appareils
sécuritaire qui
se mature au pouvoir et qui vit comme
l'a dit d'ailleurs juste titre le
président de la République dans des
crises permanentes avec l'ancien
colonisateur
exploitant une rente une rente
mémorielle qui ne s'épuise jamais
[Musique]
au pouvoir et les Tunisiens un régime
ultra autoritaire sans Parlement
mention ouvertement raciste à l'encontre
des populations subsaharienne qui est en
train de nous exporter en France donc
c'est ainsi cataclysmique pour la
Tunisie qui est extrêmement pauvre et en
crise très profonde c'est
un normal
dictatorial autoritaire et dans une
gagie économique considérable en Algérie
le pays qui s'en sort le mieux c'est le
Maroc qui est surmonté tout ça
et la France réussit le prodige de ce
discuter avec tout le monde et pour la
première fois de se disputer en même
temps avec l'Algérie et le Maroc c'était
quand même sans précédent dans
l'histoire d'habitude on avait tantôt un
problème
on va rentrer dans le détail Pierre
Lellouche mais d'abord à qui mais le car
oui alors on a entendu ce qui est dit
sur
les trois pays et notamment la Tunisie
c'est votre avis
oui la Tunisie invente la Tunisie est
dans l'accélération du temps ils sont
arrivés à la démocratie avec un petit
peu de retard y compris par rapport à
leur situation sociale éducative parce
que la Tunisie est très éduquée depuis
très longtemps et puis il y a eu 10 ans
de démocratie avec un vice original qui
était la Constitution les Tunisiens ont
fait une constitution en 2013 que le
monde entier a applaudi c'est une
Constitution pour les Norvégiens c'est à
dire une constitution fondée sur du
consensus parce qu'il voulait il y a une
alliance entre la gauche et les
islamistes pour que personne ait le
pouvoir donc le pouvoir était réparti
partout et du coup le pouvoir est
exercer par personne sauf les parties
sont mis d'accord pour se répartir les
postes le résultat c'est qu'ils ont pris
aucune décision que les espoirs nés du
de la révolution du printemps arabe etc
ont très très vite été déçus et puis il
y avait un glissement vers un système de
plus en plus autoritaire avec l'appui
des jeunes c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire c'est que les soutiens du
président actuel ce sont d'abord des
jeunes et il a fait campagne pas pour
dire qu'il allait mieux gérer la Tunisie
mais qu'il allait débarrasser la Tunisie
des voleurs et aujourd'hui d'une
certaine manière c'est de son point de
vue ce qu'il est en train de faire il a
installé une constitution ouvertement
dictatoriale avec un blanc sain des
Européens pas des Américains mais des
Européens et il est en train de détruire
tous les corps intermédiaires les
parties les élus on pensait que c'était
impossible de faire tomber les
islamistes c'est fait il a changé la
Constitution on pensait que c'était
impossible il l'a fait maintenant il a
supprimé toute liberté de la presse il
commence à s'en prendre aux hommes
d'affaires et la suivante sur la liste
c'est évidemment la France ouais alors
Jean Dufour là vous venez d'entendre ce
constat
quel est le vôtre en tant que
j'allais dire experte stratégique
moi je pense que je répare la totalité
de ce qui vient de dire dans la mesure
où je pense que il y a quelque chose qui
a beaucoup changé quand même c'est la
jeunesse et je pense que l'intervention
de la jeunesse dans le cours politique
tel que c'est présenté en Tunisie et en
Algérie montre je dirais qu'une force se
crée qu'elle s'exprime qu'elle a un
certain degré de d'intervention qui
reste pacifique et je pense que tout
change pour qu'elle change non je pense
qu'il se passe quelque chose et je me
pose moins la question qui est une
question de chercheur est-ce qu'il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui la naissance d'une
espèce de conscience d'une jeunesse
maghrébine qui a je dirais qu'il est pas
un peu les frontières et les
nationalistes mais justement je voulais
vous
interroger sur ce point précis ces pays
maghrébins restent des pays jeunes avec
des jeunesses qui sont à la fois en
révolte et pour nombre d'entre eux
acculés au chômage notamment les
diplômés qui cherchent à émigrer
ils sont éloignés du pouvoir et le
pouvoir semble les ignorer comment vous
expliquer ce décalage alors même s'il y
a un réveil de la jeunesse mais cette
jeunesse n'est pas intégrée alors est-ce
qu'elle est une force vive je pense que
les une force vivent je pense qu'elle a
aussi avec une certaine sagesse chercher
à établir son autorité autrement que par
le rapport de force direct et je pense
qu'il y a là une façon intéressante de
regarder l'évolution d'une société qui
est de plus en plus j'ai différencier
entre les générations la génération qui
monte qui sont d'ailleurs aussi
majoritaires dans ces trois pays ont une
façon d'exprimer leur préoccupations
leurs rêves leur esprit de décision qui
est nouvelle et je pense que nous
devrions peut-être plus attentif nous
pensons toujours aux jeux politiques
somme des experts de ce qui se passe à
Alger ou des est-ce qu'il se passe au
Maroc les rapports de force entre les
différentes courants politiques mais
s'étend assez bien ce qu'il y a dans la
tête des jeunes je pense aujourd'hui le
chercheur moi je suis en contact par mes
anciens étudiants j'ai enseignais
beaucoup ici en France à des Français
qui avaient des origines maghrébines et
qui restent très connectés je dirais à
leur pays d'origine et qui aujourd'hui
nous disent cela ils nous disent des
choses nouvelles on va rentrer là-dedans
alors je voudrais avoir votre avis à
tous d'ailleurs tous les tous les quatre
genre du four vient de s'exprimer mais
Pierre Lelouch le fait qu'il y ait des
pays jeunes et des démocraties en Europe
qui sont j'allais dire vieillis par leur
population est-ce qu'il se décalage là
et stratégiquement important
il est tout à fait fondamental dans la
mesure où moi je partage pas l'optimisme
de l'amiral du four malheureusement
j'aimerais croire qu'il y ait une
solution locale pour cette jeunesse qui
a qui attend d'avoir un avenir ce qui
est normal un pays comme l'Algérie 30%
de la population à moins de 15 ans les
trois quarts de la population n'ont
jamais connu la guerre d'Algérie c'est
la même chose dans les autres dans les
autres pays du Maghreb ce que je
constate c'est que et là je vais
peut-être dire un gros mot mais j'ai
l'impression que ces gouvernements sont
assez contents en fait de débarrasser de
leur jeunesse en l'exportant vers la
France en ce moment
c'est particulièrement significatif de
la Tunisie malheureusement
on en est à peu près de 1000 personnes
par jour
qui prennent la mer vers l'Italie qui
arrive en Italie il y en a d'autres
malheureusement qui meurt alors là
dedans il y a aussi bien sûr des gens
qui viennent de Côte d'Ivoire notamment
mais beaucoup de jeunes tunisiens
l'immigration
l'émigrations algériennes marocaines
vers l'Europe et la France en
particulier
continue à plein régime c'est un vrai
sujet nous en France l'an dernier on a
reçu quelque chose comme 350000 premiers
visa de ces jours et 150 000 demandes
d'asile
à terme ça va profondément
menacer la cohésion de notre pays il
faut le savoir la France est en train de
changer le peuple sous l'impact cette
immigration je crains malheureusement
que la solution de facilité pour ces
régimes qui essayent de se maintenir en
place c'est de se débarrasser d'une
gymnaste qui ne peuvent pas être éduquer
correctement et qui peuvent encore moins
employer
pierre je voudrais complètement vicieux
oui pierre Lelou je voudrais avoir la
vie sur ce point là de Rachid tema et da
Kimmel car oui cette dissociation
j'allais dire entre Maghreb et les
démocraties via à travers ce décalage
démographique et ce qui vient d'être dit
sur ces jeunes qui quittent leurs pays
il y a plusieurs questions bon il y a
plusieurs sujets dans la question
d'abord dire à Pierre Lelouch que la
France ne change pas de peuple ou de
peuplement je crois qu'on peut pas dire
cela et je crois qu'il faut faire
attention ce n'est pas vrai là-dessus
ensuite on sait très bien que l'Europe
est globalement une pyramide des âges
vieillissante et que le contenu
d'Afrique en amont il y a une pierre
ménage plutôt jeune ça c'est un fait et
c'est pas lié voilà c'est un fait après
quand vous êtes jeune en Algérie pour un
peu les connaître en fait il y a deux
sites pour faire simple et après deux
façons il y a ceux qui essaient dans le
système actuel beaucoup maintenant font
ce qu'on appelle du commerce en Algérie
donc de vie en Algérie et beaucoup
essaient de quitter l'Algérie et c'est
vrai qu'on a aujourd'hui notamment sur
les côtés espagnols etc beaucoup
d'adjunks essaient de fuir parce qu'ils
se disent que dans leur propre pays il
n'y a pas d'horizon ils ont parfois fait
des études mais sans perspective
économique sans perspective il y a la
question qu'on dit depuis des années sur
l'Algérie la question la crise du
logement c'est toujours une réalité
d'emploi c'est toujours une réalité et
tout ça permet vous êtes en train de
dire que c'est une défaite politique
pour qui pour le pour l'Algérie que ces
jeunes quittent le pays oui il y en a
qui restent là qui part mais parce que
le pouvoir aujourd'hui ne donne aucune
perspective à sa jeunesse
comme l'était le précédent au
gouvernement et avec le président pré en
public il y a pas besoin
de dire pierre leloucha non je disais
qu'avec la louche c'est un point
désaccord majeur c'est que il évoquait
l'arrivée de population de Tunisie
notamment et que la France sous cette
pression là changer de peuple ça
s'appelle la théorie la théorie de cela
et je crois que c'est faux vous dites ça
pierre Lelou sur ce point précis mon
excellent ancien collègue ou collègue
Rachid themal
affirmer ce qu'il veut autant qu'il le
veut mais ça change pas les choses nous
sommes encore une fois dans une dans une
trajectoire migratoire en France qui est
profondément en train de changer la
nature du peuple du peuple français
quand vous regardez les statistiques
c'est pas celle de monsieur Zemmour
c'est celle de l'Insee regardez les
statistiques de l'INSEE elle vous disent
que
40% des enfants en France entre 0 et 4
ans sont d'origine immigrée 40% s'il
allait à la sortie d'une école ou d'un
lycée en France pour voir à quel point
cette population a changé
l'histoire regardez les statistiques
démographiques donc moi mon excellent
mon excellent pierre
je vous ai pas attendu pour aller voir
les écoles et comment ça se passait
juste regrettable que sur un sujet aussi
important aussi tangible on ne puisse
pas avoir un dialogue calme moi je suis
pas là
je vous dis que nous sommes en désaccord
vous m'avez dit Pierre Lelouch je vous
ai dit juste que j'avais un point de
désaccord avec vous je suis très très
calme et vous pouvez dire que donc
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas non ces gens
là que vous évoquez là sont des Français
sont des Français ils sont français
voilà donc je crois qu'on a cette
pointure
laissez-moi donner la parole d'abord à
qui melkar oui et vous l'aurez à nouveau
Hakim el Kawi sur ce point là et en plus
les statistiques ça vous connaît
oui moi je crois pas ceux qui disent que
la France est en train de changer de
Paul donc c'est la théorie du Grand
remplacement c'est pas celle d'Éric
Zemmour c'est celle de
comment il s'appelle cet écrivain
médiocre
en fait c'est faux pourquoi c'est faux
c'est pas qu'une question de statistique
migratoire ce qui dit ça et je vous
rejoins et pardon pierre Lelou je suis
je suis en désaccord avec vous ce qu'ils
oublient c'est que la France c'est
fabriqué des Français des nouveaux
Français je viens de faire un rapport
sur le sujet s'appelle nouveau français
c'est intitulé il y a l'Institut
Montaigne il sortira ailleurs parce que
j'ai un désaccord avec l'Institut
Montaigne il a un il est intitulé succès
silencieux échec criant pourquoi parce
que on ne voit pas ce qui fonctionne
pourquoi on ne voit pas ce qui
fonctionne parce que ça fonctionne parce
que il y a pas la différence visible
l'échec la la recherche identitaire qui
fait qu'il y a une opposition avec on va
dire le reste de la population nationale
donc on voit pas la majorité des succès
on voit la minorité des échecs
et la force de la France la France est
un pays d'immigration depuis 150 ans
depuis 1850 depuis qu'on a des
statistiques aujourd'hui les chiffres
c'est quoi c'est à peu près 9 10% des
Français qui sont de confession
musulmane c'est-à-dire qui viennent du
Maghreb d'Afrique subsaharienne
musulmane et qui viennent de Turquie sur
les naissances on a 18 % des naissances
aujourd'hui qui sont qu'on peut
qualifier qui viennent du monde arabe
bon pas 40% 18% l'immigration
aujourd'hui l'immigration régulière 40%
vient d'Afrique Maghreb Afrique
subsaharienne 40%. donc pas 90%
40%. et dans la dynamique de
l'immigration ce qu'on voit c'est que en
10 20 30 40 ans on fabrique des nouveaux
Français et je vais vous dire quelque
chose heureusement qu'on a l'immigration
aujourd'hui on se plain de quoi on se
plaint cap il y a personne pour faire
des travaux peu qualifiés les
entrepreneurs les entreprises les ETI
tout le monde dit on a besoin de main
d'oeuvre
on vient d'où cette main d'oeuvre elle
vient de la dynamique migratoire
française qui contrairement à la demande
et régulière depuis les années 50 avec
une baisse à partir de 1995 et une
reprise sous Nicolas Sarkozy donc quand
la droite dit qu'elle va lutter contre
l'immigration quand on regarde les
fesses si on regarde les faits il faut
dire quelque chose c'est qu'elle n'y
arrive pas plus que la gauche le sujet
c'est qu'il faut 1 assumer que 1 on a
besoin d'immigrés de que l'histoire de
la France de sa population elle est
faite d'immigration et que 3 et c'est
peut-être le plus important le sujet
dont on parle jamais c'est que on n'a
aucune politique pour réussir l'accueil
et l'intégration des immigrés et surtout
de leurs enfants on va rentrer dans le
détail Hakim un mot pierre Lelouch et on
passe à notre sujet vous vouliez réagir
oui d'abord je notais que
l'émission est inquiétude la déconfiture
du Maghreb et on a immédiatement parlé
de l'immigration en France ce qui montre
à quel point l'échec des uns cause un
énorme problème à la France de l'autre
et moi je suis pas dans la version rose
décrite par Monsieur elkaoui donc je
connais les travaux que je que je
respecte mais malheureusement la
situation est autre d'abord j'aurais lui
rappeler que la France n'est pas un pays
d'immigration elle est depuis la
première guerre mondiale après les
loisirantes notamment qui ont résulté du
désastre humain qui a été causé par les
premières grands lois sur l'immigration
ont été celles qui ont suivi la première
guerre mondiale les migration à l'époque
elle était essentiellement d'origine
européenne et chrétienne c'était des
Italiens c'était des Espagnols c'était
des gens de l'Europe de l'Est ce qui a
complètement changé à la fin du 19e
siècle contre des Italiens que les
Provençaux la Provence étant une région
des christianisés depuis très longtemps
considéré comme trop trop chrétien donc
non non c'est trop c'est trop simple si
je peux continuer radicalement changer
se fait 10 ans après la colonisation on
a vu arriver les vaincus les sites de
gens venant d'Afrique du Nord
on a été chercher pour reconstruire la
France d'abord pour sauver la France
pendant la guerre voilà et ensuite pour
la reconstruire non la France n'est pas
un pays d'immigration depuis toujours
c'est faux certainement pas ce qui est
vrai c'est que après la Première Guerre
mondiale et après la perte de 5 millions
de jeunes Français au cours du conflit
il a fallu repeupler le pays et la loi
de la loi Miran a fait qu'on a fait
venir des populations qui venaient
essentiellement de payer européen
chrétiens d'Italie d'Espagne d'Europe
centrale c'est
la vérité incontestable ce qui s'est
passé ensuite après la décolonisation et
je rappelle que le général de Gaulle est
parti d'Algérie précisément à cause de
ce facteur démographique et la crainte
de voir des vagues migratoires il
voulait tourner la page de cette
histoire vers l'Algérie on a vu arriver
des vagues migratoires avec la
bénédiction d'ailleurs du patronat
français à l'époque qui faisait venir
des dizaines d'abord des gens sans leur
famille puis après le la réponse
familiale en 76 on est passé une
immigration deux masses et de peuplement
qui a profondément changé la structure
urbaine et nationale du pays c'est une
réalité en vous a entendu Rachid est mal
juste une réaction parce qu'on va passer
à autre chose oui non mais moi j'ai
aussi beaucoup de respect pour pour le
ministre Lellouche la vérité c'est que
ce qu'il dit qu'il a saigne c'est faux
la France dans ces frontières et dans
son peuple c'est une terre d'immigration
et ça il peut dire ce qu'il veut je vais
laisser vite monsieur Lellouche dans les
relisez dans entre l'entre-deux-guerres
notamment ce qui était écrit notamment
sur les polonais ou sur les Italiens il
y avait mes endroits c'était interdit
aux chiens et aux Polonais et au
Polonais aux Italiens donc ils étaient
déjà ils étaient chrétiens comme quoi la
réécriture est assez intéressante
ensuite vous évoquez une autre
immigration en fait moi je vous donne
des exemples précis ils ne sont pas
venus après décosition ils sont venus
pendant la guerre pour sauver la France
puis pour reconstruire la France
notamment c'est ce cas ce qui s'est
passé et je vous le dis oui il y a des
millions de Français des millions de
Français je crois que il y a des études
c'est-à-dire il y a des millions de
Français qui ont des origines étrangères
qui sont des parfaits français et je
crois qu'il faut faire attention à ce
qu'on a combien 30 % 30 % sur des
Français moi je vous donne un exemple
concrets monsieur Lelouch je suis le
premier de la famille a été français et
français ouais c'est pas très compliqué
bien on est on est des Français comme
tout le monde et la France Escalé c'est
ça aussi sa richesse sa beauté de savoir
effectivement faire de tous ces
individus là des Français et un peuple
comme il peut y avoir un désaccord dans
une émission
[Musique]
alors Jean Dufourcq il y a une question
que je voudrais vous poser qui a été
invoqué de manière subliminaire à
travers les différents propos selon
Pierre Nora l'histoire rassemble mais la
mémoire divise et sépare
ensemble le confondre à propos du
Maghreb parce que l'Algérie le Maroc et
la Tunisie sont à la fois une affaire
diplomatique et une affaire intérieure
est-ce que cet entre deux cette
emmènement est-ce qu'il vous paraît
permettre de voir les véritables
problèmes qui se posent en France ou
dans les pays du Maghreb ou est-ce que
tout ça s'en mêle
c'est une question tout à fait
intéressante qui est le chercheur a
envie d'analyser rapidement mais je
pense que la peut-être qu'il est au
départ une idée fausse l'idée que les
trois pays du Maghreb auraient eu des
trajectoires comparables chacun de ces
pays a sa propre histoire si on parle de
la Tunisie la Tunisie à une histoire
assez différente des deux autres pays et
qui composent le Maghreb et donc chaque
chacun vient avec sa propre histoire
chacun vient avec ses rêves ses
frustrations sont passés ces gloire et
ses difficultés et je pense que si l'on
part de cela et bien on comprend assez
bien que j'allais dire que l'histoire
peut un peu diviser et peut aussi
renvoyer à chacun une image différente
l'histoire la relation entre la France
et chacun des trois pays du Maghreb a eu
sa propre trajectoire et cette
trajectoire est plus ou moins ancienne
et donc ce qui apparaît j'allais dire
aujourd'hui c'est que les miroirs que
l'on renvoie son numéro très différents
et je crois que c'est l'idée même de
Maghreb qu'il faudrait t'interroger
derrière la question que vous posez
l'idée de Maghreb une idée peut-être
plus moderne plus récente les
géographiques elle n'est pas encore
complètement sociologique il faudrait
pour cela que naissent ce que moi je
crois percevoir et que d'autres n'ont
pas perçu mais je crois qu'il y a une
conscience de la jeunesse pacifique qui
est en train de se créer oui avec un
langage avec une vision qui n'est pas du
tout tournée vers le bassines je
voudrais je reviens sur ma question
rachité mal question intérieure question
extérieure emmêlement des choses
impression que tout ça se mêle donc je
vous parlais de l'Algérie parce que je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est des choses
différentes sur l'Algérie c'est à la
fois une question intérieure une
question extérieure
d'abord parce que c'était trois
départements
et deuxième chose on va si on se dit
chose tranquillement
personne entre guillemets soldait la
question de la guerre d'Algérie dans
d'autres pays si je prends les
formations politiques je commençais par
ma famille la gauche la gauche est celle
qui a permis les pouvoirs spéciaux à
l'armée et tout ce que ça engendré
derrière donc elle a jamais voulu
échanger discuter regardez en face son
histoire la droite
c'est celle qui le 13 mai 58 rappelle de
Gaulle en espérant conserver l'Algérie
je vous ai compris et c'est celui qui
fera l'indépendance donc aucune
déformation positan dans notre pays en
tout cas les majeurs jusqu'à ces
dernières années non évoquer cela
d'ailleurs à tel point quand vous
évoquez la question avec notamment les
les Français Algérie ils ont débarqué on
leur a dit elles nous emmerder pas on
est en août passé votre chemin les
harkis pareil donc je veux dire par là
c'est qu'on n'a jamais fait ce travail
là donc moi je suis d'accord avec la
phrase de Monsieur Nora mais en disant
que les mémoires elle divise c'est vrai
mais elles sont surtout d'abord
complémentaires je crois qu'il faut
aller dans cette notion assez il y a une
complémentarité des histoires en
fonction de qui vous êtes de votre
parcours familial et c'est ça qu'il faut
faire aujourd'hui et moi par contre et
pour en terminer je suis très heureux
que les deux j'étais moi algés avec le
président Macron et puis ensuite avec la
premier je suis très heureux par exemple
le travail sur l'ensemble de la perte de
la mémoire
1900 1830 1962 avec les 6 ou 5
historiens de parce que je crois qu'il
faut faire ce travail d'histoire il
n'est pas fait donc ça ça permettrait
l'envie de dire de dire il y a une
histoire commune qui est à la fois
douloureuse heureuse un peu ça qu'on
veut ensuite il y a ce qui est à
l'avenir aujourd'hui c'est vrai quand on
prend les deux pays quand on prend juste
un mot les deux pays ont des problèmes
assez similaires sur les questions
sécurité sur la question la sécurité
alimentaire ou énergétique ces deux
grands géants qui pourraient se parler
mieux se parler je vois entre la France
Algérie à faire ce travail là alors
l'Algérie mais côté Maroc Tunisie c'est
moins emmêlé si on peut dire non
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez à qui met
le car oui les pays sont restés dans une
indépendance et d'esprit politique on a
moins le sentiment que les choses sont
mêlées
non je dirais pas ça c'est très c'est
très imbriqué après il y a un usage
politique qui est pas exactement le même
qu'en Algérie parce que on a un peu
moins les régimes ont moins besoin de
l'opposition française pour exister
parce qu'ils sont pas nés seulement dans
l'opposition la guerre avec la France
mais la présence française est très
forte et je pense que ce qui est
intéressant avec le Maghreb c'est la
région du monde avec laquelle la France
et une relation qui n'est pas une
relation de politique étrangère
parce qu'il y a une histoire commune
extraordinaire très complexe etc parce
qu'il y a des populations communes des
deux côtés il y a problémont 500 000
franco-algériens en Algérie et il y a 4
5 6 millions descendants de Maghrébins
au sens large y compris les Juifs les
Juifs d'Algérie y compris les appeler du
contingent les harkis évidemment etc en
France donc on est dans une zone qui est
intéressante parce que elle invente
quelque chose quand on a des populations
en commun une histoire en commun une
langue en commun même si le français se
perd un peu au Maghreb en fait il y a un
objet politique spécifique qui se crée
d'où cette omniprésence de la France du
point de vue du Sud et d'où aussi
probablement la difficulté pour la
France d'inventer une politique soit
maghrébine soit avec les pays du Maghreb
parce que la France qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait elle vient d'abord l'héritage
l'héritage c'est l'histoire l'héritage
c'est une présence avec du capital avec
un appareil diplomatique
extraordinairement important c'est le
plus important du monde avec l'Allemagne
et les États-Unis
et puis elle gère les crises le problème
c'est que elle a pas de projet politique
et quand on regarde ce qui se passe en
Tunisie je serai pas trop long le
président de tunisien il a compris une
chose c'est que les Européens leur seul
politique aujourd'hui avec le Maghreb
c'est la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine et donc il leur dit je vais
lutter avec vous contre l'immigration
clandestine et en échange vous me donnez
de l'argent et surtout vous me foutez la
paix mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que il y a tellement plus de
projets politiques que l'inquiétude de
Pierre Lelouch très émourienne pardon
pour lui mais en fait c'est ça qui fait
la politique de la France au Maghreb et
c'est pour ça que ça marche pas il faut
un projet politique à l'échelle au
niveau de notre engagement politique
avec le Maghreb qui est une imbrication
politique oui alors sur cette question
pierre Lelouch linbrication à faire
intérieure à faire extérieur qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez
je pense que je pense que là je rejoins
Rachid themal je crois qu'il y a une
vraie différence entre l'Algérie et les
deux autres l'Algérie c'était trois
départements français et donc il y a ce
lien qui est en tout cas des deux côtés
très importants et surtout du côté
algérien dans les deux autres cas la
Tunisie qui était un protectorat et le
Maroc qui a toujours été un royaume il y
a deux histoires différentes et
peut-être un éloignement plus grand par
rapport à la France et moins de moins
d'exploitation de cette histoire de
mémoire au contraire les Marocains sont
très patriotes très nationalistes et et
mais généralement je considère que ce
mélange des gens que cultive d'ailleurs
à mon sens à tort le président de la
République le grand service à personne
la majorité de la population dans les
pays du Maghreb n'étaient pas là pendant
la dépendance Allah poursuivre avec vous
gens dufourc il y a un problème de
sécurité il y a un problème de
terrorisme ce terrorisme est en Afrique
il est aussi en Tunisie pourquoi
n'arrive pas à se mettre d'accord sur
une politique de sécurité commune je
crois c'est assez simple c'est qu'on
identifie pas les mêmes choses derrière
la notion de terrorisme derrière la
notion de terrorisme il y a toujours
trois identiques trois choses profondes
il y a des questions de séparatisme qui
existent toujours et en particulier moi
il y a toujours une question séparative
c'est une question de grande criminalité
et cette question de grande timidité
s'allier c'est lié à des régimes
politiques qui ne savent pas gérer je
dirais l'ordre public et donc ces trois
questions sont intimement mêlées et ce
qui fait que on ne sait pas les résoudre
si on identifie pas exactement de quoi
on parle le mont terrorisme est un mot
complexe aujourd'hui et vous souvenez
que les États-Unis en inventant la
guerre globale contre le terrorisme ont
brouillère assez profondément les cartes
nous ne savons pas gérer cela et il est
trois pays n'en font pas face aux mêmes
questions et puis en plus là il faudrait
repartir du Maghreb en Tunisie on
regarde beaucoup la Libye on regarde
vers le sud la question du terroriste
n'est pas posée de la même façon en
Algérie et la question du Polissario
pour le Maroc est une question qui
relève aussi du terrorisme chacun a au
fond son propre terrorisme sa propre
histoire et surtout sa propre géographie
et tout ça fait que l'Algérie avec ses
deux ces deux territoires sont ça bande
côté et le reste et donc il y a donc là
des politiques qui ne peuvent pas être
coordonnées et comme il n'y a pas une
vision d'avenir commune chacun ses trois
pays ne tire pas dans la même direction
il veut d'abord solder des
problématiques avant de solder des
problèmes globaux bon alors écoutez de
la sécurité on va passer à des choses un
peu plus positives on va passer à
l'économie à l'instar de d'autres pays
africains les trois pays du Maghreb
participent de la mondialisation en
nouant des partenariats économiques
privilégiés qui avec l'Europe qui avec
la Chine la Russie la Turquie l'ensemble
du monde arabe le Brésil Israël etc mais
il n'y a pas d'intégration économique à
votre avis pourquoi Rachid
il faudrait une thèse mais d'abord on
peut rappeler qu'il y avait un projet
Maghreb 2000
qu'on constate c'est qu'il y avait eu un
temps avec une volonté il sort résultat
après c'est des écoles c'est des
économies très différentes et je crois
aucune des trois économies n'a aussi a
réussi à avoir un niveau alors l'Algérie
à son rapport hydrocarbure mais aucun
des trois pays n'a un niveau de capacité
de manufacture
qui a conséquente qui vous permet de
commercer dire c'est un vrai sujet c'est
quand vous voulez dans le dans le monde
un an il faut vendre est-ce qu'ils ont
des services formidables à répondre
c'est pas vraiment est-ce qu'ils ont de
la manufacture la réponse c'est pas
vraiment donc c'est très compliqué pour
eux d'aller à commercer ensuite les 3P
ont du mal à commerçant ensemble d'abord
l'Algérie la Tunisie ça fait 40 ans qui
s'ouvre la frontière qui fait la
frontière on peut difficilement le jeudi
entre le Maroc et l'Algérie ça fait 40
ans que ça dure les frontières se
ferment de temps en temps elles s'ouvre
qu'on venait que c'est pas facile pour
faire du commerce ensemble en plus les
deux pays ont une vision historiquement
de panafrique et qui avec des ils sont
en concurrence aussi sur ces questions
là quant à la Tunisie c'est un peu plus
compliqué son rapport économique à
l'Algérie est plus dépendant je trouve
et c'est vrai même d'un mot sur la
sécurité qui d'ailleurs impact économie
c'est que vous êtes quand même quand
vous prenez les trois pays du Maghreb
alors le reste ils ont un pays
totalement détruit qui s'appelle alibi
et là vous avez quand même une bande
théorie qui plonge jusqu'au Tchad et par
le sud vous avez notamment le Mali avec
ce qu'on a connu là donc qu'on venait
que en termes de sécurité en général le
business de la sécurité ça fond pas ça
fait pas vraiment mon ménage donc les
trois pays on voit donc à la fois une
problème interne à construire une
économie et un problème d'air ça à avoir
un pôle de stabilité oui d'accord mais
quand
même Caroline pourquoi c'est
impossibilité
de peut-être pas de faire marcher quand
même mais d'avancer vers une perspective
économique commune
ce qu'on a des tribus qui sont en guerre
les unes contre les autres c'est assez
traditionnel dans le monde arabe
on pourrait dire
au 21e siècle on se dit que c'est un peu
dommage mais
il y a cette idée que le voisin l'autre
le plus proche est un concurrent
et jamais jamais
un collègue jamais quelqu'un avec qui on
va coopérer donc on va toujours
travailler avec des gens loin et on va
toujours se méfier des gens des gens
proches et malheureusement ça c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne pas seulement
au Maghreb dans tout le monde arabe les
accords il y a des accords de
libre-échange s'accordent d'Agadir qui
ont jamais été vraiment impliqués
appliquées pardon nulle part nulle part
dans le monde arabe pour autant moi je
pense que l'avenir du Maghreb c'est pas
la manufacture c'est les services et
notamment pour les Marocains et les
Tunisiens l'économie algérienne elle est
très différente pourquoi parce que les
Marocains les Tunisiens ils ont un
avantage comparatif par rapport à tout
le reste de la Méditerranée c'est que
ils ont en commun une culture
en bonne partie une langue et puis les
fameuses échanges migratoires dont on
parle ils ont construit des savoir-faire
de prise en charge des gens des
savoir-faire médicaux des savoir-faire
hôteliers des je pense qu'il y a un
énorme marché d'économie du service
autour de la prise en charge des riches
européens dans les pays plus pauvres du
Sud de la Méditerranée la Tunisie et le
Maroc aujourd'hui on sait plus financer
regarder le sujet des retraites derrière
c'est le sujet de la santé comment on va
financer le vieillissement pas de la
France de toute l'Europe occidentale on
sait pas faire il va falloir faire
baisser les prix façon de faire baisser
les prix c'est d'exporter les services
exporter les services ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire industrialiser la venue non
pas des jeux de maghrébins qui vont
travailler en France même si on en a
besoin mais industrialiser l'avenue des
jeunes retraités européens soit parce
qu'ils vont avoir besoin de soins de
santé qu'on sait pas faire ici soit
parce que juste ils vont prendre leur
retraite passer une partie de leur
retraite dans les pays du Maghreb et ça
on peut le faire comme Maghreb on peut
pas le faire en Turquie on peut pas le
faire en Égypte on peut pas le faire en
Jordanie parce que on est très loin
culturellement et je pense qu'il faut
faire levier sur notre histoire y
compris sur la colonisation on vit en
commun on se connaît aujourd'hui qui
prend soin des personnes âgées en France
dans les EHPAD
ce sont des jeunes femmes la plupart
d'origine maghrébines ou ou
subsaharienne donc il y a plein de
choses en commun et plutôt qu'agiter la
haine la peur et pardon pierre Lelou je
suis vraiment très choqué parce que vous
avez dit essayons de travailler sur ce
qui nous unit et ce qui nous unit c'est
ça c'est notre passé commun et c'est
notre avenir commun alors pierre Lelouch
sur cette question économique comment
vous expliquer cette difficulté pour les
pays du Maghreb à commercer entre eux et
à créer justement quelque chose une
forme d'union économique
c'est moi qui suis choqué
dire le réel dans ce pays
ça n'est pas appelé à la haine au
contraire c'est l'aveuglement qui fait
le terreau de la haine et je lui dis de
faire attention à ces mots parce que moi
je suis pas là pour faire de la
propagande raciste je sais trop ce que
c'est que le racisme donc essayez
d'avoir les yeux grands ouverts sur
votre pays
j'ai fait depuis 6 ans beaucoup de
travaux sérieux quantitatifs sur ces
questions et j'ai toujours dit ce qui va
et ce qui va pas mais pas seulement ce
qui va je peux pas continuer ma phrase
pourquoi est-ce que ces trois pays ne
coopèrent pas
pour une raison simple dans le cas de
l'Algérie qui est le pays le plus riche
les choix de la direction militaro
sécuritaire hydrocarbures et de vivre de
cette rentrée ils n'ont pas développé le
pays
les choix de Benali c'était le tourisme
de masse européen et ça à peu près
fonctionné le reste du pays est très
pauvre et ça a donné la révolution de
2011 le Maroc lui a fait des efforts des
forces de développement et
d'industrialisation qui sont
considérables et je vous recommande par
exemple d'aller à Tanger et regarder y
compris ce que nous avons fait et
conséquences étaient au gouvernement en
termes de délocalisation contre l'emploi
en France on a fabriqué les usines
d'automobiles on a exporté des moyens de
transport moderne le Maroc
a construit un système bancaire ce qui
un système de service qui est
extrêmement performant dans le monde
Afrique et eux ils sont en train de
bâtir une économie qui est assez
convaincante après il reste
naturellement la question du Paro
occidental et la tension avec l'Algérie
qui est un frein supplémentaire à la
coopération entre le Maroc et l'Algérie
mais tout ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que les idées d'un grand Maghreb
économique n'existe que dans les rêves
des élèves des Européens c'est pas dans
la tête acteurs sur place chacun a son
mode de développement je sais pas si
c'est une constante du monde arabe
peut-être
mais en même temps moi je note que pour
le regretter d'ailleurs que les pays qui
ont de l'argent dans le golfe mais très
peu d'argent dans le Maghreb la Tunisie
a besoin d'investissement l'argent il
vient pas du golf par exemple et c'est
tout à fait regrettable donc il y a pas
de communauté là aussi de l'envie de
développer ces pays pour elle merci
Pierre
merci Pierre jantes Dufour je rebondis
sur cette question que je trouve
importante et je crois qu'il faut
élargir un peu le champ du Maghreb et
vers un petit peu les pays latins qui
sont en face les trois les trois frères
maghrébins on les connaît et en face
trois sœurs latines dont on parle un
petit peu moins je crois que il y a là
quand même une possibilité de travailler
de façon un peu plus globale la les pays
la vieille Europe la France Espagne
l'Italie sont un petit peu marginalisés
dans l'Europe d'aujourd'hui qui dirigé
par la Pologne avec un regard très
différent et je crois que par contre
entre nous sommes en train de
redécouvrir la communauté de nos
intérêts entre les trois pays les trois
sorts latines et je crois que nous
pourrions faire un effort plus collectif
tout son 180 millions je dirais sur la
rive nord de la Méditerranée occidentale
il y a 100 millions de maghrébins en
face de nous nous pourrions avoir une
approche un peu plus intégrée au plan
économique en particulier et je voudrais
je voudrais un deuxième point c'est ceci
a été déjà largement déjà commenté mais
nous avons parlé de cela avec des
Italiens et pas très longtemps
il y a une vingtaine d'années on
travaillait sur le processus de
Barcelone vous vous en souvenez et on
réfléchissait à l'équation magique
l'argent du golf la technologie des
sœurs latines j'allais dire ou de
l'Europe en général et la capacité de
production de délocalisation sur la côte
d'Afrique du Nord d'un certain nombre
d'industries ou de services comme la
comme vous l'avez dit et qui permettrait
je veux dire à tout le monde d'être dans
une logique gagnant-gagnant pourquoi ça
n'a pas marché ça n'a pas marché
essentiellement pour des raisons
accessoires secondaires le terrorisme
bien sûr et puis des changements du
monde à l'époque et donc tout cela a
créé une condition qui n'a pas permis de
mobiliser ces trois outils simultanément
pour pouvoir créer un développement qui
soit de bonne qualité et qu'il soit
durable et qui laissait chacun un petit
peu chez soi aussi au centre de gravité
de ses qualités alors d'un point de vue
géostratégique Jean
aujourd'hui le mot sans qu'il y ait une
nouvelle guerre froide le monde se
divise en quelque sorte entre des
puissances dites autoritaires certaines
indices des dictatures on parle ça la
Russie on pense à la Chine etc et puis
autoritaire et de l'autre côté des
démocraties est-ce que par rapport à
cette division le Maghreb vous paraît
avoir devoir s'aligner quelque part ou
vouloir jouer une position non alignée
qui pour certains pays est plus proche
des pays autoritaires et pour d'autres
vers l'Occident alors la question d'une
non alignement est une question
mental de l'époque que nous vivons
aujourd'hui 2023 l'obligation
d'alignement est actuellement en train
de décréter un certain nombre
d'initiatives il serait souhaitable
effectivement que nous arrivions à créer
cette communauté andalouse dont on a
parlé à 20 ans rappelez-vous à Émile
cette communauté andalouse dans
lesquelles les pays qui sont
gestionnaires d'un même espace arrive à
retrouver sans je dirais
conditionnalités politiques des intérêts
communs qui permettent de les rassembler
dans une communauté qui soit réellement
au service des peuples et là
l'alignement sur l'autorité ou sur la
démocratie à moins de sens il faut bien
dire que la démocratie est déclinée
aujourd'hui de façon très variée et
quant à l'autoritarisme il est lié
finalement à l'histoire de certaines
d'un certain nombre de pays qui
cherchent leur propre chemin je vois
cette dichotomie ou cette ce clivage
n'est pas pertinent aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il faut revenir à une forme de
régionalisme en tout cas le stratégisme
vous dire à cela dans lesquels les
intérêts communs sont plus faciles
percevoir la globalisation étendue des
champs très vastes la régionalisation
permet de retrouver des solidarités
immédiates et je pense que la
Méditerranée occidentale si elle savait
ce concevoir aurait aujourd'hui des tas
d'outils pour ce développer dans
l'intérêt général Pierre leloupin mot
sur stratégique sur la la question du
Maghreb par rapport aux puissances
autoritaires et aux démocraties un mot
là-dessus
est-ce que pour le Maghreb c'est mieux
de choisir si je puis dire l'Occident
démocratique ou d'aller vers ces
puissances autoritaires qui constitue
quand même 60% de la population mondiale
page des maths sur cette question sur
cette question il y a des gens une
réalité c'est que
on sait bien que les rapports je parlais
de l'Algérie France - Algérie sont
distendus depuis des années faut pas il
y a beaucoup de choses du gouvernement
algérien mais en France on a notamment
fermé les toute la petite de visa en
tout cas largement réduite notamment sur
les étudiants il y a un des outils aussi
de Software pour la France c'est dans
des étudiants les former puis tout ça
aussi bon mais déjà aujourd'hui il faut
pas qu'on se monte sur la question
militaire
l'alliance historique elle est avec la
Russie pour l'Algérie aujourd'hui dans
le business quand vous allez en Algérie
la Chine est partout
donc aujourd'hui les bailleurs de fonds
de l'Algérie c'est beaucoup déjà mais
vous le déplorez moi alors moi je le
déploie cette personnel mais en même
temps si j'élargi je sors de ma
condition personnelle
tous ces pays africains pour une grande
part les trois qu'on connaît mais plus
largement ils ont été colonisés et puis
depuis ils ont des relations
privilégiées avec la France est-ce que
on peut constater que toutes les
populations sont heureuses de leur
développement et ben elles font
aujourd'hui comme ça se passe dans le
monde entier elles se disent il y a
plusieurs compétiteurs qui viennent nous
proposer leurs services on regarde plus
offrant c'est ce qui se passe notamment
sur l'arrivée des Russes notamment et
pas que avec Wagner mais notamment
Wagner l'arrivée des chinois sur un son
de pays l'arrivée des Turcs aussi via
l'entrée de la Libye et vous en avez
partout donc aujourd'hui tous ces
pays-là sont très largement concurrencés
effectivement ça devient des zones de
concurrence
pour des compétiteurs internationaux on
va conclure là dessus Hakim El Karoui
finalement à travers tout ce qu'on a dit
au cours de cette émission envers et
malgré tout est-ce que le Maghreb est
une chance pour la France et
réciproquement alors là je vais citer
pierre Lelouch je vais je vais dire que
c'est une réalité pour la France je sais
pas si c'est une chance ou une malchance
mais en tout cas ça existe et le sujet
c'est qu'il faut qu'on vive avec et je
crois qu'il faut qu'on arrête de croire
que on va pouvoir laisser la question
maghrébine et la question des Maghrébins
très loin de notre horizon politique et
pour ça il faut se poser la question de
qu'est-ce qu'on a envie de faire avec le
Maghreb il y a 20 ans il y avait l'idée
de faire une intégration économique pas
trop politique c'était compliqué et de
toute façon c'est rester compliqué
aujourd'hui on a abandonné cette idée
d'intégration économique y compris parce
que ça a assez largement échoué moi je
crois que il faut faire du judo le judo
c'est c'est où la valeur et c'est où le
partage comparatif qu'on a l'avantage
comparatif qu'on a c'est que on se
connaît les uns les autres extrêmement
bien on vit ensemble dans une forme de
fureur mais aussi de passion et en fait
on a plein de choses à faire il faut
juste arrêter de se dire qu'on se
déteste on se déteste pas tant que ça on
prend soin les uns des autres ben
faisons levier et faisons faisons de
cela un projet économique et du coup un
projet politique alors Jean Dufour
diagnostic une chance pour la France
pour l'Europe et vice et versa à
l'évidence rien n'est plus important
pour la France que le Maghreb et
j'ajouterai rien n'est plus important
dans le Maghreb pour la France
aujourd'hui que l'Algérie retrouvait un
chemin de coopération et un chemin de
coexistence qui débouche sur quelque
chose de plus large je crois que oui
c'est une chance je crois que nous
devons faire quelque chose nous sommes
obligés de le faire d'ailleurs parce que
c'est notre intérêt et parce que nous
trouverons aussi des retours très
positifs dans notre société française
qui regarde cela comme une sorte d'ovnik
trop difficile à gérer quoi il faut y
aller racher des mâles
j'ai un rêve moins de 20 ans à peu près
après la deuxième guerre mondiale vous
avez vu le traité de l'Élysée
on est 60 ans après il faudrait
interdire soit l'Élysée soit d'Alger
entre la France Algérie je crois que
c'est ce qui maintenant l'enjeu pour la
France notamment cette zone là du monde
c'est pas trop tard vous pensez pas
les populations sont comme vous le
disiez une population toujours là la
réalité elle est toujours là donc je
pense qu'il faut maintenant aller vers
cela un traité je pense d'amitié entre
deux peuples nous avons quelques
problèmes de connexion avec Pierre
Lelouch mais nous l'avons au téléphone
alors pierre Lelouch à votre tour de
conclure sur un pronostic est-ce que
vous diriez que malgré tout le Maghreb
est une chance pour la France et pour
l'Europe et
vice et versa
sera une chance pour le Maghreb parce
que le Maghreb continuera à avoir besoin
des transferts d'argent de technologie
et surtout
d'accueil pour sa jeunesse donc l'Europe
restera très très importante pour le
Maghreb pour nous je crains
malheureusement que ça reste un homme
fardeau
et nous payons chouette clair nous
payons notre colonisation voilà et donc
nous sommes
la zone de destination de l'immigration
de toute cette jeunesse qui ne trouve
pas à avoir d'avenir dans les pays
d'origine et qui naturellement viendra
surtout en France d'ailleurs 82% des
immigrés algériens viennent en France
c'est l'histoire de la colonisation
c'est la langue et donc pour nous ça
restera un énorme farnaud en termes de
capacité d'accueil et d'intégration de
ces populations avec la question
fondamentale du devenir de l'islam
est-ce que l'islam
[Musique]
merci
du terreau de l'échec des expériences
que post coloniale dans le monde arabe
et notamment dans le Maghreb merci
Pierre Lelouch le moment est venu de
vous présenter une brève bibliographie
alors je voudrais rappeler que la revue
Hérodote a consacré un important
dossier au Maghreb c'est paru au premier
trimestre 2021 et le dossier est assez
riche d'ailleurs sur l'ensemble du
Maghreb je voudrais rappeler de Pierre
Vermeeren qui est professeur à la
Sorbonne déni français notre histoire
secrète des relations franco-arabes chez
Albin Michel
je voudrais également rappeler un livre
qui a soulevé de grands débats qui
livrent de l'ambassadeur Xavier
DRIANCOURT qui a été ambassadeur de
France en Algérie qui a publié l'énigme
algérienne aux de l'Observatoire
Jean dufourc qui est avec nous a publié
de très nombreux articles notamment sur
la Méditerranée le Maghreb dans la revue
de défense nationale dont il a été le
rédacteur en chef à qui melkaroui on
peut vous avez publié de très nombreux
ouvrages
puisqu'on a évoqué la situation
française vous avez également publié un
livre sur l'islam une religion française
qui a paru chez le débat Gallimard un
mot là-dessus ça évolue un peu la la
situation de l'islam français un mot ça
a du mal à trouver son organisation mais
il y a comme une bonne nouvelle c'est
que maintenant on dépend plus du CFCM
c'est à dire de l'ingérence
turque algérienne et des organisations
marocaines on est passé à autre chose au
Forum de l'islam de France qui est
naissant mais qui est fondée sur des
gens
qui sont français indépendants de bonne
volonté ces trois caractéristiques
nouvelles et donc avec ça je pense qu'on
va pouvoir construire quelque chose de
bien en même temps le vrai sujet il est
pas là il est dans l'emprise sur la
définition religieuse auprès des jeunes
notamment des quartiers populaires qui
sont en quête identitaires et la réponse
elle ne sera jamais institutionnelle
sera sur le terrain sur les réseaux
sociaux merci Rachid il y a un livre
dont vous voulez faire la promotion
vous êtes présenté suffisamment le livre
pour éclairer vos téléspectateurs
vous remercier d'avoir participé à cette
émission merci à l'équipe de LCP de
l'avoir permise et avant de nous quitter
je voulais vous soumettre cette pensée
de Béatrice Gibelin qui est d'ailleurs
la rédactrice en chef de l'excellente
revue Hérodote les relations du Maghreb
avec la France sont au combien plus
intenses et plus étroite qu'elle ne
l'était pendant la colonisation
[Musique]